[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster unconsented kissin and
this is a show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about and
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts we don't have
an expert Derek yeah that's a good point
but what we do have is some very
interesting news which will bring to you
at the end of the video and some other
stuff we want to show you with you
throughout this video so stay with us
for the next few minutes and let's tell
you what's going on right so I mean
firstly you can probably see this isn't
on your studio or boarding these guys is
we've had to move from our studio due to
issues and we found a new studio but as
you can see it's looking a little bit
around shackle so what we're gonna be
doing is we're gonna be transforming it
we're going to be turning it around
we're gonna be transforming it into an
incredible new studio that you are gonna
be able to enjoy and watch new episodes
of trigonometry with amazing guests well
not just amazing guests but also you've
been complaining about the quality of
the sound so check out these mics you
can probably hear us very well if not
we've spent a tremendous amount of money
for no good reason the quality of the
video is going to be great as it always
has been
we're gonna have you know a better
studio in every respect we're gonna keep
getting great guests that we always do
and it's pretty expensive guys we spend
a lot of money on this so as you
probably know by now we have a patreon
account now if you can support us we
like like I said we've literally spent
thousands of pounds already even before
doing up the studio which will show you
the process of how we are putting it
together so we've got some people
already who helped us out you know you
know think about this if you met us
you'd probably take us out for a drink
if you loaded you'd probably take us out
for a meal if you can give us 5 10 15 20
bucks a month that will really help us
to keep this show going because right
now what it is is literally two broke
comedians myself from Francis funding
this ourselves because
we believe the conversations we have
here trigonometry are incredibly
important and because our cursor in the
gut yeah well they're more in the gutter
now because we do this yes so so support
us and we've had already we've got a
bunch of people already we've got some
tier two patrons Rakesh Martin Adam Kay
and Chris Baker thank you guys so much
for for subscribing to us on patreon and
helping us out we've also got some tier
one patrons who are ste playing Richard
did the wonderful shame of some of them
kind it was wonderful
it's a great name mate it sounds like he
writes third-rate novels yeah also did
you notice that how Francis sounded
really excited about tier 1 tier 1 is
actually the lowest tier but he doesn't
know that
yeah pretty much
exactly okay this is not a great patreon
fits I'm an idiot
give me money yeah so here's our news
guys the news is that the season 1 of
trigonometry is now officially over yeah
yeah it's sad however we are going to be
back with season 2 and we've got an
amazing first guest just for you so you
know it is it's gonna be do a little
drum modeling your knees I don't I did
not know he was gonna say that I'm
leaving but we can't make week I'm
talking to our producer now we cannot
put this in the [ __ ] video no
seriously we're gonna get him back you
know the best is there gonna be some big
comment like why do you wanna get left
with people and Nazis when there's new
socialists but believe you put in
another hjw cut alright do you remember
how he was talking about our careers
being over there over now yeah that's
fine but actually season 1 is over but
we do have one final brilliant guest for
you who we're gonna record not in the
studio but on location and we'll be
putting out that video out next week so
he still got some great content and
we'll be back next month with season 2
with some absolutely fantastic guests in
the meantime guys keep liking keep
talking
if you could share it if you could tell
a friend about it we've got loads of
great interviews you might miss one or
two go back over them
and yeah and then we will see you soon
we will - very soon take care have a
good week and we'll see you in a week's
time with one final episode for this
season we're gonna take a break and
we'll see you yeah it was great yeah
he's gonna put that in now yeah that was
great